l'industrie porcine est inquiète à cause
de cette peste dont on parle énormément
la voilà la fameuse ppa c'est la peste
porcine africaine
ça touche bien sûr les peurs mais aussi
les sangliers les phacochères et aussi
les potamochères qui sont peut-être
moins connus ici mais quand même ils
sont visés par cette fameuse peste alors
il ya trois choses importantes à savoir
hazeb la première c'est qu'il n'existe
pas de traitement pas plus qu'il
n'existe non plus de vaccins
la bonne nouvelle si on peut dire c'est
qu'il n'y a pour l'instant eu jamais de
cas de transmission entre le port est un
être humain alors les modes de
transmission c'est là aussi que ça pose
problème parce que ça se répand assez
rapidement d'abord il ya des contacts
entre un animal infecté et un autre ça
peut très vite se répondre là la mort
est assez rapide aussi on parle de
quelques jours dans certains cas
contamination également lorsqu'il via
des équipements de ferme porcine qui ont
été contaminés qui pourrait être un
vecteur la nourriture aussi dans
laquelle on aurait décidé de mettre du
port qui étaient contaminés auparavant
ça peut aussi causer problème et puis il
ya aussi cette fameuse petite bête
l'attique molle qui est en fait aussi un
vecteur de contamination pour ce fameux
virus alors petit historique
écoutez ce comme le dit qu'on me le dit
la peste porcine africaine jusqu'en 1957
c'était vraiment confiné justement à
l'afrique subsaharienne
et puis eu des cas de contamination n'a
commencé à voyager notamment 1960 là
toute la péninsule ibérique portugal la
sardaigne également et l'espagne ensuite
en 2007 un autre foyer s'est déclaré
du côté de l'europe de l'est plus
précisément en géorgie et puis ça a
commencé à envoyer un voyage et ça s'est
rendu dans les années 70 dans les
caraïbes
et puis le plus grand qu'elle honte on
parle maintenant c'est évidemment en
2018 c'était l'année passée c'est la
chine qui est le plus gros producteur de
porcs et regarder des chiffres
importants il est actuellement 130
foyers de contagion là-bas en chine
il y à un million deux cent mille port
qui ont dû être éliminés
et on pourrait penser que ça pourrait
aller jusqu'à 200 millions ce serait le
tiers la production porcine chinoise
justement cette peste porcine inquiète
l'industrie canadienne d'ailleurs on m'a
demandé justement producteurs d'être
très vigilants
la par rapport à oui exactement pour
l'instant bonne nouvelle il n'y a pas de
cas du tout ici au canada la prévention
semble fonctionner très bien
quelques chiffres importants on est le
septième producteur mondial il y à une
industrie de 24 milliards de dollars
8000 ferme majoritairement manitoba en
ontario au québec et c'est quand même
100 mille emplois donc si j'aime ont été
touchés ça pourrait faire très bien la
zone
merci beaucoup frédéric